Every backend system that you will ever
build all of them will have one common
requirement which is it needs to be able
to handle multiple things at once
because if you have a web server an HTTP
based web server which is what we mean
in this context when we are saying a
backend application if you have a web
server which can only process one
request which is coming from a web
browser. If your server can only process
one request like that coming from a user
at a time then all the other say
thousand users who are also trying to
send their request they either have to
wait or they will get an error that the
server is busy processing one request.
So you'll have to wait and that of
course that is a very impossible
situation and it will not work in a
actual production application where we
have thousands of users. So
understanding how our servers and in
turn how our operating system can do
multiple things at once and all the
different ways that different
programming languages and different
runtimes like NodeJS or Python or Rust
or Go. The way they let you handle this
or the way they let you express this
requirement of yours to be able to
handle multiple things that plays a very
important role in forming your mental
model while you're building your
application. This particular video has
nothing [music] to do with any kind of
technique or any kind of tips or any
kind of concrete actionable items that
you can just watch the video and go
ahead and implement that. But this is
important in the sense that you can form
a mental model about how your back end
process your requests, process all the
requests that are coming from your
client and how it can perform multiple
tasks. Having that level of
understanding will help you debug
things. It will help you structure your
application a little better and will
help you forming the bigger
architectural decisions down the length.
Most of us when we are learning to
create [music] these backend systems, we
learn from our respective programming
languages APIs or its documentation that
keywords like async and await. Using
this will help us make things concurrent
or will help us make things work
together and using threads. They help us
parallelize our executions. But we don't
really understand what these keywords
actually do behind the scenes. and how
they actually help us on a mechanical
level. We know that they help us and it
works and we can go a long way without
understanding how they work and the
mechanics of it. But it's always good to
understand how they work to get one step
ahead in understanding your systems. So
in this video what I want to do is I
want to at least I will try to give a
clear mental model of how things work
from ground up starting from the root
level to handling or interacting with
your application code. Okay. So with
that premise we can start. So one
particular scenario that you can relate
to or one particular scenario that you
will face in your day-to-day life as a
backend engineer is dealing with
requests because of course that's where
all of it starts. So let's start from
there. We have a browser let's say a
single client. We have a user and it is
using Chrome to make a request to our
server. This is our backend server and
we have all this routing layer, service
layer, handler layer, repository layer
that you already know. But the gist is
we receive a request from our client and
we need to process it. And to process
it, what do we mean? We need to make
some kind of database interaction. This
is our database. We need to make some
kind of query, wait for the response
while our database does its own
execution, its own processing, and send
the response back. That's what a typical
API call looks like. Now, let's talk
about this time. be sending a query to
our database and the time [music] when
we are waiting for our database to
process that request. Now talking about
this particular time on a local network
while you are running your server in a
local host this processing time might
take somewhere around 1 to 2 millconds
assuming it's a very simple database
query and going further with that logic
let's say we have deployed it in
production and our database is in a
different availability zone so this same
query might take somewhere around 20 to
30 milliseconds and if our database is
in a different region itself Then the
same query might take somewhere around
90 to 100 millconds if it's a very far
region. And now my question is while the
server is waiting this time basically
either [clears throat] 2 millconds or 30
mconds or 100 millconds during this time
what is our server doing right that is
the question that we are trying to
answer in this video. Now going by our
naive approach assuming that our server
can handle only one request at a time
which was the premise that we
established at the start of this video.
So if we go by that premise if our
server is processing synchronously which
means line by line execution without any
kind of concurrency then during this 2
milliseconds or 30 mconds or 100
millconds our server is doing nothing.
the CPU of our server is completely
idle. That's what we say in technical
terms while it is waiting for our
databases network packets to arrive.
Right? So let's let's try to quantify
let's try to give some numbers to this
amount of waste that we are causing by
keeping our server CPU idle. So a modern
CPU, the kind of CPUs that we have
access to today, the kind of CPUs that
we work with today, they can execute
around roughly speaking 3 billion
instructions per second, which means 3
million instructions per millisecond. So
we are saying that our server is waiting
and sitting idle for 100 millisecond
straight while it is waiting for the
response from our database. It could
have executed 300 million instructions.
300 million instructions it could have
executed but instead since we are only
processing one request at a time how
many instructions it ended up processing
ended up executing zero. So this is the
amount of waste that you'll cause by not
making your program concurrent by not
doing multiple things at once. Now let's
try to quantify it even further. A
typical mid to complex level API call it
will involve three to five database
queries. It might also call one to
external services like sending emails or
interacting with radius to get things
from the cache or insert things into the
cache. And each of these operation so in
total let's say there are five
operations involving external services
whether it is database or email provider
or radius. So in total the API call
involved five different network
operations and if we say on average if
it spent 50 milliseconds waiting for
each of the network's response then in
total it spent around 250 milliseconds
waiting for network's response basically
or in other words we say waiting for IO
input output all these operations
whether we are dealing with network or
we are dealing with files or we are
dealing with standard input or standard
output like input from keyboard or
showing on display etc etc. So all these
operations are categorized as input
output operations. But this is only the
time your server spent waiting for the
responses of different different network
calls. But your server also did some
amount of CPU level processing, right?
And that was only 10 milliseconds. It
only used the CPU for 10 mconds. But for
the rest of the 250 mconds, it just
waited for the responses of different
different network calls. Which means
that your server your server's resources
your server's hardware resources CPU and
memory they were idle 95% of the time
you were not using any of your
computer's hardware 95% of the time and
this is exactly the problem concurrency
tries to solve while we are building our
backend applications if you notice most
of the times or more than half of the
times our application our program it
either waits for the database response
or it waits for external API calls like
email cache etc etc or it waits for file
system right if it is dealing with
temporary files or file uploading file
downloading etc etc all these which we
call as IO more than 70% of the time in
a typical backend application is spent
on IO and what is the use of concurrency
using this mechanism called concurrency
which means to oversimplify doing
multiple things at once. So using this
mechanism concurrency we are able to
make use of our CPU or our memory to do
additional things to do the other things
while it is waiting for the network
calls. So for the 70% of the time when
it is waiting for the responses of the
network calls we say that while we wait
for these network calls you can use the
CPU you can use the memory for other
things. We'll talk about what are those
other things but that's the problem
concurrency tries to solve. We have one
terminology out of the way. Now let's
tackle the other one which is
parallelism which is often confused with
concurrency and for good reasons. So at
one side we have parallelism and another
side which is concurrency. What does
parallelism mean? It is exactly what it
sounds like. So we say that a program is
parallel when it is able to execute
multiple instructions. at the same time
at the same moment which means that to
achieve parallelism we need hardware
level support. So if you say that your
program is executing instructions
parallelly it means it needs two CPU
cores at least so that it can at the
same moment execute two different
instructions at the same time because
one CPU core can only execute one
instructions at one moment. That is the
limitation that we have. It is not
really a limitation and you will not
really see it as a limitation once we
are done with this video. But that's the
constraint that we have which is your
CPU one CPU can only execute one
instruction at one moment of time. So to
achieve parallelism you need hardware
level support which means at least two
cores of CPU to execute two different
instructions at the same time. That's
what we mean by parallelism. It is very
intuitive to understand. Now concurrency
is a little tricky. Concurrency also
means that we are doing multiple things
at once. But the difference is we can
also achieve concurrency with only one
core of CPU because concurrency is
primarily about structuring our program.
It is about creating our program in a
way that we can start, pause, resume
multiple instructions at any moment of
time so that it feels like we are doing
multiple things [music] even though at
one moment of time we are only using one
CPU core to do or to execute one
instructions at that moment. But since
we have structured our program or our
operating system or our programming
language runtime enables us with its
feature so that we can write our
programs in a way so that one
instruction can start here then it can
go to some other thing while some other
instruction is processing and then again
this one comes back. So so this is all
about structure that is the difference
between parallelism and concurrency.
We'll talk more about this and try to
clear as much confusion as possible. But
that is the most simplified definitions
[music]
of parallelism and concurrency. So to
express it in one way, parallelism is
about doing multiple things at once
while concurrency is about dealing with
multiple things at once. Even though we
are doing one thing at a time, but we're
dealing with multiple things at once. If
we want to visualize it. So let's say
this is our timeline and these are our
millisecond scales. This is 1. This is
10. This is 20, 30, 40, 50 and 60. This
is how time passes in one direction. Now
we have two different requests. This is
request A and this is request B which
let's say arrived at the same time which
we got these two requests at the same
time. Now this is the timeline of
request A and this is the timeline of
request B. So the moment request A
arrived in our server we started
processing it. So we did let's say some
validation here some routing logic some
JSON D serialization etc etc. So all of
this requires CPU work. So for the first
5 milliseconds right let's say this is
half this is 5 millconds. So up till
here we used our CPU. So let's imagine
for this example we have only one core
of circuit. We used our CPU for the
first 5 milliseconds and meanwhile
request B was waiting and after this we
wanted to make a database query. Of
course most of the API calls we have to
make some amount of database
interaction. So after 5 seconds of
processing we needed some response from
our database. So till here to let's say
we took around 40 mconds. This is the
time that we are waiting for our
databases response. Now after 5
milliseconds, we don't need the CPU
anymore. So the moment we leave the CPU
or the moment we don't need the CPU
anymore because we are waiting for an IO
response a network response that's when
our operating system scheduleuler or a
programming language runtime whatever is
handling thisuling it takes the request
B and gives it the access to CPU so that
it can start processing and it can start
using the CPU. So from 5 millisecond
point the request B got access to the
CPU. So let's say it took around 15
millisecond since it had a lot of
processing some kind of validation some
kind of a long recursion loop whatever.
So it took around till 15 the CPU slice
for 15 millconds it used the CPU and
after 15 mconds again it also had to
make some kind of database interaction
then again it also started waiting for
the IO. So it also waited till 50. This
is the time it is waiting for the
database to respond back. Now at 40
milliseconds our database return the
response for request A. But it's not
like the moment our database responds
back the CPU will be given instantly to
request A. So there will be some kind of
shoulduling logic or some kind of
priority based logic. So up till here
even though our database was not really
processing but our request A did not get
the CPU but at exactly 50 milliseconds
point our request A gets the CPU back
and now again it does some kind of
processing using the CPU let's say it
tries to filter out some values etc. Now
it is done at this point. It just
responds back to our client. And same
way after request A is done with it.
Meanwhile the request B the database
response for request B is also returned
and it also does some kind of processing
and returns the respond back. Now the
point that I want to bring your
attention is while request A was given
the access to CPU the request B was
waiting. It did not get [music] any kind
of CPU access and only after request A
was paused or at least it was suspended
because it was waiting for IIO. It was
waiting for a network's response after
that request B was given access to CPU.
Then only it started using the CPU for
any kind of processing. That's the only
point that I wanted to make. Even though
we had one core, we still did not waste
any amount of CPU. Of course, we have
oversimplified it with two requests. But
at a time, our server is not just
dealing with requests. It's also trying
to log messages to our standard output,
which is also an IO process, right? It
is also trying to send telemetry data,
which means external API calls. It is
also trying to run background jobs,
hundreds of different things it tries to
do. And you can imagine this CPU access
being divided across all these demands
for CPU. and the requests or any kind of
task which requires any kind of network
response or any kind of IO response they
just wait while the CPU just jumps
around does the processing work and the
moment that particular task or that
particular job or that particular
process whatever you want to call it the
moment it starts requiring some kind of
IO response it jumps from that and goes
to some other process so this is how
concurrency works and this is how we
don't waste our CPU cycles now Since we
had only one core even though both of
these requests for a client's
perspective both of these requests are
currently processing right they are both
the request B has not ended yet it's not
it has not thrown any kind of error for
a client's perspective from a highle
perspective both of them are currently
in progress that's what we say but at
this moment of time the moment you zoom
in the moment you look at the time slice
at one time window only one request is
being processed by the CPU even though
both of them are in progress even though
we are doing multiple things but at a
point of time we are only doing one. So
this is exactly the definition of
concurrency. But if we were to imagine
how parallelism looks like as compared
to concurrency, then this will change.
Request Arived, it got CPU and request B
arrived. And now that we have two cores,
let's imagine for the sake of the
parallelism example. The moment request
B arrives, since we have another core
available, the request B also gets a CPU
slice and it also starts processing. So
in case of parallelism also, both of the
requests are currently in progress. But
the difference is at this particular
time window we are not doing just one
thing. We are doing both of these things
at the same time the same time window
and that's what parallelism looks like.
Now coming back to the practical
question why does it matter? Why does it
matter for us to understand this the the
concept of IO and the concept of CPU?
What is IO bound and what is CPU bound?
Why do we need to understand this?
Because as we have already said most of
the things that happens in a requests
life cycle in a typical API call are
things that are IO bound. This means
things that are waiting for some kind of
external resources rather than doing
actual computation. And the only time
that we use the CPU is when we are doing
actual computation when we are executing
instructions in our CPU core. rest of
the things things like interacting with
the database interacting with file
system interacting with logging standard
input standard output everything
requires IIO which means sending the
request waiting for the response to come
back so we call those kinds of things IO
bound and when we are actually doing
computation let's say you are validating
so you are actually going through the
JSON bytes you're checking the values
you're comparing stuff you're adding
stuff while you are doing that you're
doing actual computation you're using
CPU cycles we call that CPU bound so
that is the difference between IObound
and CPUbound and most of our backend
applications they are IO bound for IO
bound tasks one thing which is mandatory
is concurrence otherwise as we have
already said it it cannot function if it
only process one request per second
you're wasting 95% of your resources and
that's just not reasonable because you
want to handle as many requests
simultaneously as possible and while
you're doing that you want to keep the
CPU busy with other requests actual
computing so it does not matter whether
you have one CPU core or eight. The
bottleneck is always going to be IO when
we are dealing with backend
applications. But there are some kind of
workloads which we call as CPUbound. The
things that I already mentioned like
validations or JSON dialing etc. They
are CPUbound but they are not as heavily
CPU bound. You will not notice it.
They'll mostly be finished in one or 2
milliseconds because our CPUs are that
fast. But some of the heavy CPUbound
operations are things like image
processing because in image processing
or graphics there are a lot of matrix
multiplication and heavy computation
tasks which use a lot of CPU cycles.
Same way if you are dealing with
encryption in our authentication
middleware we are verifying a JWT token.
So while we are doing that we are
dealing with encryption and very
low-level computation that also is
CPUbound because it uses a lot of CPU
cycles to process or to crunch numbers.
So for CPUbound tasks what is more
beneficial is parallelism because you
want to use CPU you want to finish all
these tasks you want to finish executing
all these instructions as fast as
possible and parallelism using multiple
CPU cores to finish these executions is
always faster as compared to concurrency
where you only use CPU for one
instruction at a time in your backend
system of course you need both you need
concurrency so that you can handle your
IO bound workloads. You can deal with
multiple database connections. You can
deal with external API calls. You can
deal with file system. You can do
logging. You can deal with background
jobs etc. All these different IO bound
workloads. But you also need parallelism
so that you can do all these heavy tasks
or any kind of computation based
operations as fast as possible. But one
thing to remember is most of the back
end applications are mostly IO bound.
they are not CPUbound unless you are
doing some niche work of video encoding
or encryption etc etc. Now let's talk
about how do computers actually do
multiple different things at once. What
are the technical elements that come
into play to make this possible and
fundamentally looking there are majorly
only two ways. First is using threads
and second event loops. So every
concurrency feature that you encounter
in any of your programming languages. So
if you work with go then it is go
routines or if you work with javascript
or typescript or nodejs it is asyncate
or if you work with java it's virtual
threads. All of these concurrency
primitives that we are aware of in all
our programming languages that we work
with on our day-to-day basis. All of
them build on these two mechanisms
mostly. It's not like they use threads
directly but the primitives that have
been built they are either built on top
of threads or the concept of event
loops. We'll talk about what these two
mean. That's what it all boils down to.
So let's talk about threads first. So to
simplify thread can be considered as an
independent piece of execution by your
operating system. We are not talking in
the context of programming languages
yet. But thread is a feature that is
given by your operating system to run a
single and independent piece of
execution in your CPU obviously. So when
you create a thread or uh a piece of
logic, a piece of program which will be
run independently on top of your
operating system, your operating system
allocates or it creates or it assigns a
couple of things. First is stack. And
what do we use the stack for? For
keeping track of our function calls. For
example, if it starts with a main
function, then main function called
another function like get users, we'll
keep pushing different function calls
which was called after which in the
order into the stack. Same way we also
keep our local variables. If we have a
function, let's say we have a main
function and here we say let a equals to
3, then this variable that we created,
this variable that we assigned, the
memory for this will be inside our stack
and apart from stack OS also creates an
instruction pointer and what is the use
of instruction pointer to keep track of
where exactly we are in our execution
workflow in the code. So it keeps a
pointer to that so that it can come back
to it after the context switch. Now one
critical property, one behavior of
threads and it is an important property
because this is where it differs from
other models of concurrency like event
loop and all which is the the the piece
of logic also called as a scheduleuler
which decides if we have multiple
threads let's say 1 2 3 which thread
stops which thread starts and which
thread blocks resumes all these things
is decided by a scheduleuler and the
important property is this scheduleuler
is controlled by our operating system.
That is an important property because in
the later part we'll discuss how a
certain programming language runtimes
they also have a scheduleuler on top of
our operating system scheduleuler to
make things more efficient to make
things more lightweight. But
traditionally speaking threads are
scheduled using a scheduleuler which is
controlled by our operating system. So
what does the scheduleuler actually do?
It gives each of the thread a time or a
time slice for doing what? for some
amount of processing using our CPU. So
each thread is given a time slice for a
particular amount of CPU processing
capability and usually it's in
milliseconds. It might be less also but
we measure it in terms of milliseconds
and let's say if it assigns somewhere
like 2 millconds to each thread preigned
then after 2 milliseconds the
scheduleuler will go ahead and pause
this particular thread. It will save the
state of it like what was the last
instruction that it was trying to
execute. It will save that information
and it will switch to another thread to
start processing that and after another
2 millconds it will switch to thread 3.
So that's how the basic schedule
shoulder algorithm works. We will not go
into operating system should schedule
shoulder algorithms and all. It's it's a
huge topic. People have written books
about it. If you are interested more to
learn about threads and operating system
shoulduling and everything then you can
read a book. One of the most popular
books is this one operating system three
easy pieces. A very good book to give
you that that intuition that
understanding of how our operating
systems actually work. Then you can make
more sense of all these abstractions of
our programming language concurrency.
But anyway that's optional. That's your
choice if you want to go down that path.
And another thing is this type of
shoulduling after a given time the
shoulduler pausing a thread and starting
the execution of another thread. This is
called preemptive shoulduling because
threads or executions are preempted or
stopped before they're finished whether
they like it or not. It's not in their
control. So coming back to our IO
problem when a thread let's say it it
performs a blocking operation. What do
we mean by blocking operation? which
means any kind of operation any kind of
activity where the CPU cannot do
anything right the CPU is useless which
is any kind of input output operation or
any kind of operation which deals with
devices for example we've already talked
about things like logging or network
calls which is basically dealing with
your network card dealing with packets
TCP HTTP and all these things same goes
on database calls database call is also
kind of a network call only But no it
can be considered as a major category.
So all these things we already know are
blocking calls or IO calls where CPU is
useless. CPU cannot do anything. CPU can
only do raw processing, crunching
numbers, crunching information, all
these things. So whenever a thread
encounters any kind of blocking
operation, it goes ahead and it tells
your operating system that I have
encountered an a blocking operation, an
IO operation. So I cannot really do
anything until that completes. So what
your operating system does it marks that
particular thread let's say in this case
it is thread number one so it marks that
as blocked as in it cannot be processed
by CPU at the moment and it switches to
a different thread is thread number two
and when the IO of thread number one
completes let's say it was a database
query if the database comes back with a
response then this becomes runnable
again it's not like it will instantly
the moment we get the response it will
again get the CPU processing capability
but it will be put in a state some state
so that the scheduleuler can pick it up
again when it gets the opportunity
another important property of threads
which I should also mention is if we
have two processes I don't think we
talked about processes yet let's say we
have process one and process two so
every time you run your program it can
only run as a process as a process of
your operating system So if you have two
process even though they are from the
same program or the same code if you
have two processes then the thread from
process one is isolated from a thread
from process two right it makes sense
because of security reasons because of
memory corruption reasons and they
cannot see each other's memory. That is
a very important point to remember. But
if we have two threads let's say in
process one these are the processes and
these are threads let's say. But if we
have a thread two for process one, then
these people can share memory. All
right. And what do we mean by memory in
the first place? Memory like the heap or
global variables in your program or
anything that gets allocated
dynamically. The interesting thing here
is if thread one allocates let's say a
an object or a strct if you're dealing
with Go or an object if you are dealing
with JavaScript. If thread one allocates
an object or a strct in the heap or in
memory then thread two can also access
that particular object using a pointer
using the address of that object. Okay.
Another important feature of threads.
Two threads can access the memory of
each other as long as they are in the
same process. This particular memory
sharing this is very powerful because
threads two different threads they can
communicate by simply reading and
writing to the same memory place or the
same data structure or the same variable
whatever data structure that we are
talking about it can be a map it can be
a particular variable global variable or
any kind of storage. So the
communication happens through shared
memory and since all of this happens
through pointers because they know the
exact address of that particular
variable that particular map in the
memory there is no kind of copy no kind
of serialization anything that's why the
access the thread access is also pretty
fast but this particular property of
threads and the fact that threads
communicate by sharing the memory This
can become very dangerous and we'll
discuss that part the dangerous part in
the later part of this video. But the
point here is if you have multiple CPU
cores you have let's say two CPU cores
then multiple threads thread 1 and
thread 2 they can actually execute in
parallel at the same time window. Let's
say 0 to 50 millisecond. Both of these
threads can run in two different CPU
cores at the same time. We're not
talking about concurrency. We are
talking about parallelism now. Same way
if you have four cores then four threads
can run in parallel. And as you have
already discussed using this kind of
parallelism truly can speed up any kind
of CPU bound work that your program is
trying to perform. But one discussion
that always happens when we are talking
about thread is the cost or also called
as an overhead of using threads. What
kind of overheads that we're talking
about? The first one is memory. As we
have already discussed, each thread
whenever our operating system creates a
new thread, it's also creating a new
stack for that thread for pushing
function calls, variables and all these
things. And this particular stack size
on an operating system like Linux, it
can be somewhere around 8 mgabytes. Even
though most of the memory in this 8
mgabytes is just virtual memory, the
actual physical space is not assigned
until it is needed. So that feature is
there. That feature is provided by the
operating system. But it still comes
with some megabytes of memory the actual
physical space. So even if you are
talking about kilobytes of space for
stack, let's say your programming
language or your framework, it creates a
new thread for each request it gets.
Even though no kind of framework does
that but assuming it deals with HTTP
requests that way using a new thread so
that they can work concurrently and
sometimes they can also work parallelly.
So if you get 10,000 requests during a
traffic spike, which means 10,000
threads, 10,000 native operating system
threads and assuming each one has around
like 500 KB or even 1 MB, we're talking
about 10,000 and more than around 8 or 9
GB of memory just to deal with HTTP
requests. Your server also needs memory
for a lot of different kinds of tasks,
hundreds of different kinds of tasks.
they will quickly run out of memory and
your program is eventually going to
crash or your server might also
eventually going to crash. So this thing
is already clear that thread is very
memory heavy because of the requirement
that each thread comes with a cost of
creating a particular stack of some
kilobytes or some megabytes. Second kind
of overhead is the creation overhead. So
every time we want to create a thread,
every time our programming language or
our framework wants to create a thread,
it has to make a system call to our
operating system kernel. And once the
kernel receives this system call, it
does a couple of things. things like
setting up the stack as you already
discussed, allocating different data
structures that it needs to internally
manage this particular thread, things
like instruction pointers. Then at last
adding it to the scheduleuler to
schedule it, pause it and block it etc
etc in different different phases. Now
all these things can take somewhere from
a few microconds to a few milliseconds.
Now that's that does not sound like a
lot of time in terms of human perception
but when we are talking about function
calls we are talking about running our
programs this this is a major overhead
this can be a major cause of latency
that's about the creation overhead of
threads. Then the last one which is the
most important one and the major cause
of latency most of the times is the
context switch. So imagining we have
three threads going on and we have a
scheduleuler here. So every time our
schedule shoulder wants to switch from
thread one to thread two or thread two
to thread three or thread two to thread
one or thread three to thread two
whatever any kind of switch from one
thread to another. First thing it has to
save the current threads CPU registers.
Then it also has to update all kind of
bookkeeping to keep track of the state.
Then it has to select the next set that
it wants to run. then fetch all the
saved registers of that thread, the
thread that it wants to run currently
and the bookkeeping, the state
management, all that. So restore and all
these things can take somewhere around 1
to 10 microconds in our modern hardware
at least. So if we have four cores of
CPUs and you have around 100 threads, so
this scheduleuler, our operating system
scheduleuler has to constantly juggle
between them like and constantly switch
between them. And we are talking about
microsconds and milliseconds of context
switching time for each switch depending
on where is your data whether it is CPU
cache or not. And if we are talking
about thousand threads then this context
switch time can go beyond milliseconds
and milliseconds of time. And the
context switch time is primarily very
unproductive. We are not really doing
anything. It's just a maintenance work.
It's just work that needs to happen
before the actual work happens, the
actual processing happens. So all these
milliseconds and milliseconds of CPU
time that you are wasting on context
switch can be spent on actual programs
processing and making the program faster
and this is one of those reasons threads
per request at least this kind of model
has always struggled in terms of high
concurrency high concurrency
requirements. Now the second method that
our operating system has to do multiple
things at once. The first one that we
discussed was threading using threads to
do multiple things at once. The second
one is the event loop model. Now the
number one difference that we can see in
the event loop model at least is instead
of having multiple threads to do
multiple things at once. In the event
loop model we usually have one thread
and that one thread and using this
mechanism of waiting and using callbacks
and all these thing that we'll discuss.
It does all these multiple things but it
does not solely depend on the number of
threads to do multiple things at once.
So usually we have only one thread and
the key differentiation here is the the
number one thing that we have to keep in
mind is we can never block the event
loop and what do we mean by not blocking
the event loop. So when a particular
task let's say the request A it needs to
do some kind of database query. So this
request a instead of blocking and
waiting for the response of the database
it says that okay I want the result of
this database it says that to the
program to the event loop using the
primitives of your language mostly it's
using the async syntax it says that okay
I want the result of this particular
database query from this function and it
says when we finally get the response
back from our database then only resume
my functionality until then I am handing
of the control of CPU execution so that
you can run other things. The moment it
does that it is pushed into a queue. Now
event loop has multiple cues and
multiple algorithms priorities and all
these things that is a completely
different topic of discussion but you
can imagine it as a simple queue. So the
moment some kind of IO happens using the
event loop mechanism the task hands over
the control back to the event loop and
it pauses until the IO is complete. So
the event loop keeps track of all these
tasks that are currently waiting for any
kind of CPU processing but they are
blocked because of some kind of IO
operation. To support this functionality
the programming languages cannot
themselves implement this. The operating
system has to support this. So in Linux
we use something called eol provided by
the Linux operating system. Same way for
Mac OS operating system we use something
like KQ. So all these things that are
provided by our operating system they
make event loop possible to to make
concurrency easy basically and using
these things the event loop can monitor
all these thousand different connections
at the same time in a loop. So every
time the iteration of a loop runs it
checks whether the IO operation is
complete or not. If it is complete then
it puts that task back into the queue
depending on the priority of course and
it resumes its functionality resumes by
giving it more CPU processing time. So
on every loop iteration check for IO
operation completion then run call back
then back to the loop. This is how the
event loop works in a very
oversimplified way. And because of this
setup, because of this singlethreaded
call back and loop based setup of our
event loop architecture, we can have a
lot of efficiency. When it comes to
IObound problems, you have to remember
that when it comes to CPUbound problem,
the more the number of threads, the
faster our program is going to execute.
But when it comes to IO bound problems,
it does not matter how many threads that
you have. In fact, the more number of
threads, the more amount of context
switching it happens. and eventually
your program becomes slower. So for
concurrent workloads as we have already
discussed and for IO bound workloads
event loop works better. Event loop is
more efficient as compared to the
threading model. Threading based
concurrency. No kind of context
switching happens here because you only
have single thread. There is no multiple
megabytes and gigabytes of stack memory
because you only have single thread. So
a lot of problems related to memory and
latency and context switching comes down
because of the fact that we are only
using single thread for performing our
event loop. But what is the trade-off?
The trade-off is you can never block the
event loop. For example, if your code in
your programming language, if you do
something which is CPU intensive or
CPUbound task which takes let's say 100
milliseconds or more. So during this
time your event loop completely stops.
It cannot do anything. it just waits for
that particular task to finish. That's
why in an event loop based architecture
in an event loop based concurrency
handling mechanism our priority is
always to not block our event loop ever.
Anyway coming back. So our priority when
we are dealing with event loop based
architecture our callbacks whatever we
execute after IO or the CPU processing
part they have to be fast and usually
talking realistically in a most of our
backend applications in SAS backend
applications. We do not really have any
kind of task which takes like 100
millconds and any kind of tasks which
are this amount of CPU bound. mostly
only if you are dealing with animations
and images, video rendering or ML
workloads all these things then only you
take this much time but in a typical
backend SAS workload the latency is
always because of IObound stuff and this
is the reason because of this limitation
because of this constraint of event loop
based architecture any language which
uses event loop for example JavaScript
they make use of these callbacks
promises
and async weight all these primitives
all these primitives are basically
syntactic sugars all these convenient
functions so that you have the right
mental model of how your program is
going to work you do not write any kind
of blocking operation so that you get in
the way of your event loop so all these
primitives that is provided to us by
JavaScript and it can be the same for
other programming languages also asynch
primitives they they just help you to to
to to give up your control at particular
IO bound operations at particular points
for example the moment you start a
database query you write await right or
the moment you make some kind of API
call you write await and the moment you
write await you're saying that okay I'm
giving up control of my CPU slice or my
processing so that when this particular
network operation is complete I will be
given back the CPU processing capability
so that I can finish this particular
function. So these are all syntactic
sugars or syntactic convenient functions
so that it is easy for you to deal with
the event loop. Let's understand how in
the context of a back end in the context
of a backend dealing with different
different requests at the same time and
doing different IO operations like
database operations works in different
different concurrency models. how it
works in a threading model, how it works
in the event loop model and how it works
with languages like Go which uses a
different kind of setup which we'll
discuss. So this is how it works with
the first kind of setup which is the
threading model. We use multiple threads
to do multiple things at once. So
imagine we are dealing with two
requests. One is request A and one is
request B. The first thing that happens
is our back end receives a request which
is request A. And the first thing that
you do after receiving a request is we
parse whatever the JSON body or whatever
the query parameters that are being sent
in that particular request and which is
a CPU operation because it deals with
parsing bytes and loading it to memory
and all these things. Okay, so this is
pretty much straightforward. Then what
happens after we are done with all the
parsing and all the validation etc etc
we want to make a database call and this
is what our query looks like. Select
star from users. This particular handler
deals with returning all the users from
our database and sending it back to the
client sending back to the front and for
that we want to run this particular
database query which is select star from
users. Now to go a little deeper into
how this particular query works in
phases. In the first phase, we establish
a TCP connection with the database or if
we have a pool, we get a connection from
the pool and use that connection to send
some bytes. The information that you
want to receive this particular query,
we send it over to our database. We have
a database which our back end talks to
and we send this query to our database.
Now after we send it, we have a socket
using which we are communicating with
our database and we use that socket for
the read operation or basically we are
waiting for any kind of response from
our database using this function read on
our database socket which is a blocking
operation which is an IO operation the
kind of operation that we've been
discussing for so long any kind of
operation which our CPU does not have
any power over or it it it does not have
the capacity to do anything in that
situation because it mostly depends on
external things. So in this case this is
one of those function which is IObound.
So we have to wait for the response from
our database and the moment it happens
as we have already discussed that the
moment our thread blocks in a threading
model based concurrency the moment our
thread blocks the task tells our
operating systemuler that since this
thread one is blocked we have to switch
to a different thread. Since we are
trying to do multiple things at once the
moment something blocks because of IO we
have to switch to a different task. So
while we are dealing with request A, our
back end also receives request number B.
So we switch to request B and we start
executing that. And the same thing we
do, we get the request, we do the
routing, we do the body parsing, load it
into the memory, load it into a strct or
object or whatever your programming
language provides and then we do the
validation transformation whatever we
want and then we want to do a database
query. Now this time we want to fetch
all the orders from our system and
return it to our front end. So same
thing we establish a connection to our
database and we send this particular
query in the form of bytes to our
database in using a TCP connection. Then
on the same connection socket we call
read and we wait for the response. Then
again this is an IO block operation.
This is an IO bound operation and our
CPU cannot do anything. So again this
task tells the scheduleuler that we are
blocked. So we have to switch to a
different thread and then our OS
scheduleuler checks that if we have a
another thread which is thread number
three. So in this case if you are
creating a new thread per request or if
you have a another thread available then
it will switch to thread three and will
do the same kind of thing again. If
there are no threads then it will just
wait and block everything until one of
these IO operations are complete. One of
these database responses are received
back. The moment we receive some kind of
network packets from our network card,
then OS goes ahead. Our OS schedule
should scheduleuler whichever is dealing
with all this pausing resuming of task
and threads. It goes ahead and wakes up
thread one that okay uh we have received
our response back. You can start
executing the rest of the logic that you
have which is a CPU operation. So at
this point the database has returned the
response. Now it continues the remaining
of the functionality which is like
process the query results. It receives
some kind of bytes from the database. It
takes that bytes and it reads it, parses
it and loads it into some kind of memory
which is a native data structure of that
programming language. So if you're
dealing with JavaScript, it might load
it into objects or an array of objects.
In Python, it might load it into a
dictionary. In Go, it might load it into
a strct. So that's what we do. Serialize
it into our own data structure so that
we can read it in the process phase.
Then we take that our own data structure
our own something like strruct object
dictionary whatever we have whatever
programming language that we have then
we take that and we serialize it into a
JSON since we have to send it over the
network we have to make a network call
an HTTP call we have to serialize into
JSON assuming that's what you're using
for your serialization standard after
that we send the response back and this
particular thread which was executing
request A this goes back to the pool of
threads that we have if If we try to
imagine it as a code, let's say we are
using Python as our programming
language. Then this is what it would
look like. We have a function which
called handle request. It is the handler
which deals with this particular
endpoint. And here we make a database
query. We want to fetch a single user
from our database. So we are seeing
select star from users where ID is this
as a parameter. We are passing the ID of
the user. And the moment we do this,
this becomes a IO operation or a network
call. So at this point our thread blocks
right assuming that we are doing a
threading based execution. It is not
async aait based execution that which
you might be more familiar with. So this
is a threading model. So we don't use
any kind of async aait or the event loop
based architecture. So the moment we do
it our thread blocks whichever thread
was executing this particular function
it blocks and switches over to another
thread if that exists or it waits for
the response back from our database. And
the moment it gets the response back
from our database gets the CPU
processing time again and it starts
executing and returns the response back
to whatever the parent function is. So
this blocking operation at this point if
we take a look while we are reading the
code as a human it looks like okay this
executes and then this executes and
since it all happens in microconds or
milliseconds it looks like okay we are
just going from line by line it's all
sequential but the blocking operation is
not visible to us. the the the the
switch between different threads that is
not visible to us but it is happening
behind the scenes. So this is how a
threading model based multiple request
handling works. Now let's look at how an
event loop based multiple request
handling would look like. So first we
have request a the similar kind of setup
that we had with threading. There is not
much of difference when it comes to the
sequence of operation that happened or
the result that we got using threading
and kind of results that we'll get while
using event loop. There is not much of a
difference there but the difference lies
in the pausing the blocking and the
resuming of operations and how efficient
it is. So first we get the request
number a and as usually we will parse
that particular request for any kind of
body query parameter etc etc so that we
understand what exactly the client wants
from us. Then we start our database
query. So same kind of setup we
establish a connection with our database
using TCP connection. We send all those
bytes and we register a call back. Now
this is how it it differentiates. We'll
look at the code of how this looks like
in a bit. But what we are saying in an
event loop based architecture at the
point of where we are giving up control
back to our operating system saying that
okay this operation is now waiting for
an IO response that is the reason I'm
giving up control so that you can
execute more tasks while I am waiting
for IO using a CPU processing and that
it does by registering a call back. So
it says so something like db.query query
it runs this and it also passes a
function a piece of logic and we call
this a call back which means once the
result of bitquery returns we want to
run this piece of function that's why we
are calling it as a call back okay
that's how the event loop based
architecture works it all works on top
of call back sludge okay now the moment
it does that it it returns and what do
we mean by return it's not like we will
return the response of that HTTP request
no it basically switches to another task
while we were parsing request A let's
imagine request B also arrives so the
moment request A pauses for IO the
moment request A hands over the control
of CPU processing because of the IO
blocking we pick up request B as in the
event loop picks up request B okay now
it does the same thing it passes the
HTTP request it makes a different
database query with the TCP connection
and It establishes or it registers a
different call back a different piece of
logic that it wants to run for request B
and again it switches. Now while this is
happening how does it check that whether
the database response of request A is
completed or not. That's why we call it
as a loop. So you can imagine a loop is
running. In each iteration it checks
whether the IO of A is completed or not
whether the IO of B is completed or not.
So each iteration of that loop you can
imagine it as a infinite loop and it
keeps running the loop keeps running
that's why we call it as an event loop
and with each iteration it checks
whether the IO operations are complete
or not the ones for which we have
registered our call backs for which we
have a particular piece of function that
we want to run when that particular IO
response is back and how does it monitor
this how does it wait for all these IO
responses how does it know whether they
are complete or not using OS OS level
functions as we have already mentioned
for Linux it's using eole for Mac OS
it's using KQ and something for Windows
right and using these it becomes very
efficient to check for all these IO
responses in each iteration so let's say
after a couple of iterations of event
loop while it is doing other things like
logging things to a standard output or
doing some kind of email sending etc etc
in a couple of iterations it saw that
the DB response of request B has been
completed okay so what happens the eole
connection monitoring it returns it
returns and it says that socket B is now
readable. So the database socket from
which we were expecting bytes back some
kind of response back now it is
readable. So the moment we do that the
call back that it had registered the
piece of function that it had said that
after the database query returns the
response for request B we want to run
this piece of logic the one that we had
registered now it starts running that
using event loop and it does all the
different kind of processing loading
data into the data structure as we did
in our setting model and returns the
result back to the client after doing
the JSON serialization etc all the
boiler plate stuff after that the
database response for request A also
comes back and we run the call back for
request A and we send it back as a
response back to our browser. Now, now
it all looks kind of the same. The only
difference is instead of pausing the
thread and resuming the operation from
the instruction that we're running at
that particular point of time before
pausing. The way we pause and unpause in
an event loop based architecture is
using callbacks. And when we use
threading model use make use of
operating systems native data structures
operating system native instruction
pointers all these heavy data structures
to resume our operation. But in an event
loop based architecture use callbacks to
resume our operation back. Now if you
try to see the code of how an event loop
based concurrency looks like this is a
JavaScript code where we are using event
loop to perform concurrency or basically
dealing with multiple requests at once.
So this is what it looks like before ES6
JavaScript version. This is how we used
to do concurrency the upper part where
we have a function we are receiving the
request and the function to send
response back some kind of abstraction
over request of JSON. So we are calling
this function which is our database
driver which has the database connection
this TCB connection handling logic. So
this is our query select star from users
and we want to fetch a particular user
ID which we are receiving in our
request. Now in the third parameter as
you can see we are passing a function an
anonymous function and we are saying
that after this particular piece of
logic runs this particular IO response
is received right so after our event
loop receives the response back from our
database the result of that is going to
be available in this function if there
are some errors it will be in the first
parameter and the result is going to be
available in the second parameter and we
can use that value in this particular
particular call back. So this is what we
mean by call back. A particular piece of
logic that we provide beforehand to our
event loop. So that the moment this
particular piece of logic returns some
response, we run this function. So once
we get the user, we send it back to our
client using this send response function
using these parameters. Right? This is
what it used to look like. Now with
modern JavaScript after ES6, this is
what it looks like using async commit.
So we have the similar function and we
run this database query and we pass the
user id but there are no callbacks.
Okay, we are just using two more
keywords. One is async, the second one
is await. This async await based syntax
is just a syntactic sugar on top of
callback. So I don't want to go too deep
into the JavaScript ecosystem. But the
the problem with this kind of setup the
call back based setup the reason we came
up with this async aait based syntax is
let's imagine you want to do another
database query and another API call
after you get the response from this
particular database. So in the call back
you have to write another database query
right select star from orders or
whatever then for that again you have to
pass a call back and if you have let's
say five or six of these async
operations six of these IO bound
operations and for each of those you'll
have to pass a call back so after a
point it will start looking like this
okay there are more and more nested
functions inside each of these and that
continued for a long time before we came
up with this async. So previously we
used to have these kinds of functions
where we had a lot of these nested
callbacks. So to prevent that to make it
more readable they came up with this
async await based syntax which is just a
syntactic sugar and by that I mean the
moment you write await whatever comes
after that at least in the context of
this function I don't mean in the
context of the whole program for this
function the moment you write await
whatever comes after that until the
completion of this function until the
last line of the function that you can
imagine is being passed as a call back
to this IO blocking operation. So this
is same as writing this but when we
write like this we can do multiple IO
blocking operation and we won't have any
nested call backs. The idea is the same.
The moment you write await you hand over
your control to the event loop saying
that until we get the response back from
our database you can do other stuff and
the moment you get a response back you
can continue from this point. Okay. And
your event loop handles all that using a
single thread. There are no context
switching and no expensive stack memory
allocating by your operating system. So
everything happens in a very efficient
manner and a very lightweight manner.
That's why event loop is considered more
efficient than the threading model as
long as we are talking about IO bound
operations. We are not talking about
CPUbound operations. For CPUbound
operations, threading will always be
faster than event loop. Next, let's take
a look at another interesting
concurrency model which is not exactly
threading and not event loop. Also, it
uses something else. We can consider it
as a virtual thread. And we call it
virtual thread and not thread because
when we say thread, it is a an operation
an entity which is managed natively by
your operating system. It is not
something that your programming language
or your programming runtime handles. The
facility is managed by your operating
system which we already know is
considered heavy because there is a lot
of overhead related to memory creating
and switching. So, Go uses a different
approach which we consider as a virtual
thread. But you will not see this term
being used when you're working with Go
or when you're reading documentation of
Go or anywhere. They don't call it
virtual thread. they call it a go
routine. Okay. So the conceptually they
can be considered as a virtual thread
but they are called go routines and the
moment you start a go program it it runs
as a go routine and that go routine the
main go routine can also create other go
routines while it is running. Okay. So
that's how the go programming language
works. We'll not go too deep into go in
this video. We'll just focus on the
concurrency model of how go concurrency
works. So one interesting thing with Go
is as a backend language when you are
using Go the standard library Go creates
a new Go routine which is a virtual
thread for each request and in the start
of this video at least when we were
talking about the threading model we
discussed that create if you create a
separate thread for each of the requests
that you're receiving then you might run
out of memory because each thread comes
with some megabytes of overhead and
eventually if to create like let's say
10,000 threads or 20,000 threads
eventually you'll run out of memory
because threads are very expensive but
if you take a look at go's code the
standard libraries code the source code
of the go programming language then
there is this function which is the
serve function this is the function
which basically accepts all the incoming
connections listens for new connections
and it creates a new goin for each new
HTTP request that it receives and it
assigns a handle handler a particular
handler that you had configured
beforehand while writing code and it
assigns that handler to deal with that
request. So if you go to this line at
the end you can see that it is creating
a new go routine in go programming
language you can use this keyword called
go to create a new go routine or create
a new virtual thread and whatever
function that you pass after writing
this keyword that will run as a new
virtual thread or as a new go routine.
So go programming language by default it
creates a new go routine for each
request it receives. We are talking in
the context of back end now. So imagine
this scenario we have two requests
request A and B and first we receive
request A it created a new go routine
our programming language runtime and
then we got request B it created another
go routine. Okay now we do the same kind
of stuff. We parse the request we do
validation transformation. We load it
into memory by d serializing into a
strct and all those stuff. Then we get
into the database stuff. Same we do the
TCP connection stuff. We convert our SQL
query into bytes. We send those bytes
and wait for network. Now the moment
that happens, we know that this is a IO
block operation. Right? Same for go
routine 2 also. We do all this stuff and
the moment we run the database query,
this is an IO block operation. The
moment it happens the go runtime
scheduleuler we'll talk about what this
is we're not talking about OS shoulduler
it's not anuler which is provided by our
operating system it is go runtime's own
scheduleuler it pauses this particular
go routine the same way our osuler our
operating system scheduleuler pauses a
particular thread switches the context
goes to the next thread and start
executing the go runtime shoulduler does
something similar but instead of dealing
with actual ual operating system level
threads. It deals with go routines which
are kind of a virtual thread which only
exist in the context of go runtime.
Okay. Now same thing happens the moment
some kind of IO operation starts and we
start waiting for the response the go
schedule shoulduler it pauses that
function and it moves on to some other
go routine right the go routine two
maybe or go routin 3 if there are
thousand go routines because for each
request we are spinning up a new go
routine we may be switching into any of
those thousand go routines that does not
matter okay now let's talk a little bit
about the go runtime shoulduler how does
it network. If you remember the
threading model, which you should
because we literally talked about it 10
minutes back, it is exactly the same
which happened on this layer, the
operating system level threads which we
only had a limited amount of for good
reasons because threads are expensive.
They come with a lot of overhead
overhead like creating overhead,
switching overhead and the memory
overhead of maintaining all the stacks.
So we already know this model of
execution creating and using different
operating system level threads to do
multiple things and it usually relates
to how many CPU cores that you have
because in one CPU core only one thread
can execute at a time. Okay, it is not
necessary that the number of threads are
directly related to the number of CPU
cores that you have. So even if you have
one CPU core, you can have four threads
but at a time only one thread will be
executing in your CPU. We already know
this layer of execution how threads
work, how the context switch happens,
how threads are created, a new stack is
allocated, the instruction pointer is
created and the data structures are
created to maintain the state of the
thread and all these things. Right? This
layer now comes another layer, the go
routines layer or the go runtime
scheduleuler. Now this is not related to
our operating system. This is something
which comes with the Go programming
language. This is embedded. Now this is
where the magic happens and this is why
Go is such an efficient language when it
comes to both CPU and IO. Even though it
is not using an event loop based
architecture but because of this Go
runtime scheduleuler based architecture,
it manages IO operations so efficiently.
So this is how it works. For each
operating system thread there is a flag
that you can set while starting a go
program which is go max which means how
many threads that you want to create by
default how many CPU cores you have that
many threads are created right so let's
imagine you have four CPU cores and four
operating system threads are created now
you're capped at four threads for your
go program that's the first fact and
these are those four threads m1 m2 m3
and m4 now for each time you create a
new go routine the go runtime shoulduler
it assigns that particular go routine or
it pushes that particular go routine
into one of these cues. So each
operating system thread you can imagine
it as a queue and depending on some
algorithm your go runtimeul it pushes go
routines into these cues. So one
operating system thread will be dealing
with multiple go routines at once. So
instead of dealing or instead of
creating, pausing, switching all these
things on operating system level
threads, now you're dealing with go
routines. You're still doing the
resuming operation, the switching
operation and the memory thing, all
those things. But now it's much more
lightweight because the go runtime is
handling it. And when you actually
switch from one go to other, it is
usually just a pointer switch, which
means you just take the pointer and you
point it to something else. Okay? And
that thing is pretty lightweight. So for
that reason at a time we can spin up
like thousands and millions of go
routines depending of course you'll run
out of memory at some point but compared
to the number of threads that you can
create the operating system level
threads you can create 100 times more go
routines because the mapping happens
like this. So going back to our earlier
example, let's say there are two
requests, two HTTP requests and since we
create a new go routine and this is the
reason the go HTTP package creates a new
go routine for each request because go
routines are so lightweight that we do
not care. We can afford to create a new
go routine for each request. So if G1 is
blocked for some kind of IO operation,
for any kind of database operation, the
M1 thread, the M1 OS level thread, now
the execution of course happens on the
OS level thread, which means at a single
point of time, the OS level thread M1
takes one of these go routines and it
runs it. The moment G1 blocks, go routin
one blocks, it pauses G1, which means
the go runtime pauses G1 and M1 starts
running G2 now. Okay. And if we take a
look at the code of how a particular go
handler would look like. This is what it
looks like. We have a function here and
it takes the request returns a response
and this is the database query. We are
running this function DB.query. This is
our query. Select star from users where
ID equal to this. We are passing the
user ID in the second parameter. And the
moment we do this this particular go
routine whatever go routine that was
executing this function it pauses and
the go scheduleuler picks up another go
routine. Maybe it's another request or
maybe it's a logging operation or
whatever and it starts executing that
and when this response comes back this
particular go routin which was paused
because of this IO operation now it
starts executing again and it sends a
response back to the client. Now, okay.
So, the distinction, the primary
distinction here is the virtual thread
method is kind of the same as the
threading model, but we are dealing with
another layer of abstraction. Instead of
operating system leveler, we are using
the go scheduleuler. Instead of
operating system threads, we are using
the virtual threads also called as go
routines. And that is the reason it is
so lightweight. Another thing that
causes a lot of confusion at least in
the event loop model is how does the
async await keyword works because in
different different programming
languages like Python, JavaScript, Rust
and all that. So let me talk a little
bit about that. Consider this particular
function. We have a function here which
is fetch user data and the parameter is
a user ID. We take that user ID. We run
the first query, the database query
which is to get the user DB.get user. We
pass the user ID and we await that which
means this is a blocking operation and
by writing await in front of this
function we are saying that we are
giving up the processing to our event
loop until this is completed and all
this should be put into a call back
function which will only run after we
get the response back from this
function. Okay. Now the moment we get
the response back from this function
this call back all the code after this
line this starts executing again we have
a database call here. So we hand over
our control back to the event loop and
we start waiting for the response of
this and this will be put into a call
back which will only get executed after
we get the response back from this
function and after we get the response
back from this function we take the
result and return it back. So this is
what it means from all the discussions
that we have done so far. To make it a
little more technical how our
programming language deals with it, you
can imagine it as a state machine. So
the same function we can convert it into
this function. Now the signature is the
same. We have a function the name is
fetch user data and the parameter is a
user ID. So we can imagine an async
function as a state machine which
interacts with the event loop. Let's say
for user ID while running this function
we passed user ID as 1 2 3 and we start
executing. In the first step our state
is zero. We are initializing a variable
called state and while starting out it
is zero. And we also have two more
variables to store the users and also to
store orders. Then we define another
function inside this function and which
we will keep returning again and again.
And since in JavaScript functions are a
first class citizens you can return
functions from other functions. So we
define this function which is called
step and we return that after defining.
Now when this function runs what happens
we have a switch statement here and
depending on which state we are in we
run that particular state. Okay. So by
default in the first execution run the
value is zero. So in case zero the
moment we enter the execution we make it
as state one. Okay we increment the
value of state to one. And this is where
the IO blocking operation comes. We call
this database function and we pass it
the parameter. And in the then statement
which is the call back part. We are
assigning whatever results come back
from the database query and we are
assigning it to user since we are trying
to fetch the user in the first place.
And we go to the next step. And since
this is a state machine kind of setup
and the caller when it runs this
function so during this state transition
so in the first await the moment we
write the first await keyword we are
running this part the first state which
is the state equals to zero and after
this completes we hand over the
transition part when this part completes
and before this part starts the state
machine execution one starts during this
time our event loop is free is not
executing this function function. Of
course, it is executing other racing
functions or other racing functions, but
it is not executing this function. And
after we get the result of database,
after we get the user back, we
transition into into state machine
execution one. Then again, we do it the
value two, we call this async function
in the call back. We assign the result
to orders variable and when we
transition into the next state and after
the event loop pauses and then the
result of this returns and we go to the
execution two and finally we return user
and orders. So you can imagine this is
kind of how your programming language
runtime executing async functions as a
state machine. It goes from one state to
another every time we use an await
keyword. If you understand the state
machine kind of setup, a couple of
things that become clear is one why can
we only use await inside async
functions. Why? Because this function
the moment you write async in front of
that function that has to be transformed
into a state machine. That's why if a
function is not marked as async you
cannot use the await keyword. Both of
them work together as a state machine.
Second, why blocking the event loop is
so bad? Because if you block the event
loop, which means that state machine
will never get to go to the next state,
it cannot go from state zero to state
one, from state one to state two. So
it's important that we never block the
event loop. Right? Of course, you don't
have to internalize all these things.
You don't have to understand deeply all
these things. How your programming
language runtime converts async
functions into state machines. How all
these concurrency primitives works
behind the scenes. But it it it helps if
you do understand it. And like any
system concurrency also comes with its
own set of problems. And most of the
time all the different kinds of
problems, different categories of
problems that are caused due to
concurrency is because of this single
reason which is shared state or shared
memory. To understand a few of these
problems, let's take this very simple
example which is a counter example. And
what we are trying to do, we have two
different threads and they are trying to
update a variable which is this counter
variable which starts with the value of
zero and they try to update this
variable at the same time or
simultaneously in a concurrent way. Now
to take a variable and increment its
value with one a thread has to perform
three different operations. First, it
has to read the current value of the
counter into a register into a CPU
register. Before it can perform any kind
of operation, it has to read the current
value. Then once it has read the value
of the counter into the register, it
needs to add one. Now the value of that
register becomes one. Once that is done,
finally it can take the value of this
register which is one and write it back
to the counter variable which is this
one. So to increment the value with one,
it has to perform three different
operations. Now imagine this kind of
scenario where two different threads are
trying to increment the value at the
same time. And this is a timeline. So
you can imagine it as millisecond 1, 2,
3 or second 1, second 2, second or any
kind of time unit as you want. So at
millisecond 1, f a started first as a
step one read the value of this counter
variable into the memory which is the
value of zero. And at the same time at
millisecond 2 before thread A could even
increment its value in its register
thread B read the value of the counter
variable into the memory which is the
value of zero. And at millisecond 3
thread A incremented its own resistors
value one. And at millisecond 4, thread
B did the same thing. It increased the
it added one to the register value. Then
finally at millisecond 5, thread A wrote
the value of one into the counter
variable. So now the value of counter
variable is 1 at millisecond 5. Now at
last at millisecond 6 the last operation
that happens is thread B after it has
increased the value of its own register
it takes that value which is value one
and it writes it back to the counter
variable. So ideally since both of these
threads are working on this single
variable and they are trying to
increment its value. Ideally after
running all these operations we should
expect the value of two for the counter
variable. But because these two threads
are interacting or trying to increment
the value of a single shared variable
and their operations are intertwined in
different different milliseconds. we get
the final value of one. And this problem
is called a lost update problem which
happens when two different threads try
to operate or try to work on a single
shared variable. And because of this the
increment of one of the thread was
completely lost. This is what we call as
a race condition. And at this point you
might say that if I use a programming
language like JavaScript which has a
single thread and I use async aait so I
should not worry about the problem of
race condition or any other problem
which happens due to concurrency. Right.
Unfortunately in async await based setup
for example this code where what we are
doing we have a variable which is the
variable of balance and with the initial
value of 100 and we have a function
which called withdraw which takes the
parameter of amount. First here what we
check we check if the value of balance
is greater than or equal to amount is
the parameter that we are passed and
balance is the global variable. If yes,
then we call this function which is
process withdrawal which maybe executes
a database query. That's why we have to
write await. This is an async function.
And finally, after this is done, we take
the global variable and we subtract the
value amount from our balance because we
withdrew that amount from our global
balance. Okay, this is how it works. So
imagine we called the withdraw function
twice in some location in our program.
And when we do that, we can imagine a
situation like this. So we have our
balance variable. So we are just trying
to visualize whatever function that we
just saw in our JavaScript using async
of it. Okay. So this is the execution of
the first withdraw function call and
this is the execution of the second
withdraw function call. We pass the
amount 100 in both of these and now we
can track how they execute. So in both
of these instances let's say this
started executing first since this is a
concurrent setup this started executing
first and the first thing that we do is
we compare and what do we compare? We
compare the amount with the balance to
check if we have the balance to perform
the withdraw then we allow it. So we
checked if 100 is either greater or
equal to 100 which is true because 100
equals to 100 and we come inside and
here we have to perform an async
function and because of that we started
executing this async function and the
and the moment we do that we have to
take the control and give it back to our
event loop because that's how event loop
based architecture works. Okay. And here
at this point we give up control and the
moment we give up control the second
function started executing. We can
imagine and here we again compared the
value which is if 100 is greater than or
equals to 100. So true and we came
inside again we started with this async
function and gave the control back and
the moment we gave the control back we
came back to this function because this
is how concurrent setups work. Every
time you call await, you give up control
of your CPU so that your program can go
and execute something else while you are
waiting for your casing function to
finish or your database call to finish.
So when we come here, this was
successful and we update the value of
balance 100 minus 100 and the balance is
now zero. After we are done with this,
we come back to this. By this time, the
database has responded back. Now at this
line by the time we start executing this
the value of balance is already zero and
since this check that we made if we had
done this check after the value of
balance became zero this would not have
been true we would not have entered into
this function and since this check
happened in between this execution now
we are in this situation what happens by
the time we start executing this line
which is the balance deduction line here
the value of balance balance is already
zero because we ran this and now the
value of balance is 0. So now what
happens instead of 100 - 100 it becomes
0 - 100. So the value of balance is now
minus 100 which is an inappropriate
value which is not a valid value for
this function. So even if you use a
single threaded async awaitbased setup
you are still not free from race
conditions because this kind of
situations can also happen. So what is
the solution? How do we prevent race
conditions? This is again one of those
topics which can go very deep and you
can read more about different different
race condition prevention mechanisms
that we have available in the operating
system book. But some of the most famous
ones that I will just give a brief about
is first locks or mutexes. So this is
how it works. Imagining we are using
Python as our programming language and
we are using this library called
threading to use the locking mechanism.
So we have a function which is the
increment function that we are just
talking about and before we start
executing or before we actually perform
this operation the write operation what
we do we acquire a lock which means that
this particular statement whatever is
inside this this is also called as
mutual exclusion in technical language.
So this area while we have this lock
only one thread can enter into this
area. The moment one thread acquires a
lock and goes inside all the other
threads which are called to execute the
same function they have to wait to get
the lock and they will only get the lock
after this first function is done with
it. So with this kind of setup we can
avoid race condition to certain extent.
There are also other techniques, other
mechanisms using which we can avoid race
conditions etc etc. Like in in Go
programming language especially there is
a primitive called channels where
instead of depending on a particular
global variable or depending on a shared
variable where uh different go routines
or different threads virtual threads
whatever you want to call different
independent executions can update that
particular variable. what you do these
different threads these different go
routines they pass messages and only one
particular go routine updates the value
of that variable. So channels are
another modern solution to the problem
of race conditions. So over the time a
lot of people have come up with a lot of
solutions for all the different problems
related to concurrency. But this video
is not about the the technicalities of
dealing with concurrency and the
problems that come with it. Is mostly to
wrap our head around one single concept
which is what is IO bound and what is
CPUbound. That's the only goal of this
video. It does not matter whether you
understand all these threads, logs,
concurrency etc or not. As long as you
understand the concept of IO bound and
CPUbound, this video has been
successful. Okay. Now let's summarize
everything that we discussed in this
video. For any kind of IO bound
workloads which requires a high amount
of concurrency things like web servers,
API gateways, services that make a lot
of API calls to other services, all
these things. These kinds of primitives
prove a lot more efficient as compared
to the threading model which is like
things like async aait or go routines
which is the virtual threads for go
runtime and also if you're using Java
Java also has virtual threads in the
modern versions of it. Same way for
CPUbound workloads which means any kind
of numbers processing or string
manipulation, image manipulation, video
manipulation, any kind of core
processing, crunching numbers, crunching
bytes into the memory, out of the memory
or any kind of processing that you can
imagine which happens in our CPU which
is performed by the CPU that is called
CPUbound workloads and in those cases
threads with parallelism is more
efficient as compared to our event loop
based architecture. So all in all,
concurrency lets your program stay
productive to not waste CPU cycles while
it is waiting for any kind of IO. IO in
the sense any kind of work which is not
handled by the CPU. It can be
interacting with your network card to
send and receive packets to interact
with your input output standard input
output or making any kind of external
API calls dealing with databases. All
these things these are called IO or
input output and parallelism. It lets
you use multiple CPU cores to do
multiple things at the same moment of
time. And most of the backend work that
you will see it will lean heavier on the
concurrency side not on the parallelism
side. But again
there are cases where you might need
both or you might need parallelism more
than you need concurrency. But as long
as you understand the difference between
them you should be able to make the
right decision. You should be able to
choose the right tools for your use